Fantastic Beasts And Where To Find Them has
more deleted scenes than any of the Harry
Potter movies, according to producer David
Heyman.
Yippee ki-yay movie lovers, it's Jan here,
and I'm going to talk about some of the deleted
scenes that didn't make it into the first
Fantastic Beasts movie, as well as some of
the things we can look forward to in the Fantastic
Beasts sequel.
Of course, I'll be talking spoilers, so if
you're not ready for those, check out my spoiler-free
Fantastic Beasts movie review here.
Now, do you remember that little wisp of the
Obscurus that drifts up and out of the subway
after the final battle?
Well, although the Aurors thought they'd destroyed
the Obscurial, it was definitely a hint that
we haven't seen the last of Credence Barebone.
And there's actually a deleted scene that
would have made his setup for Fantastic Beasts
2 a lot more obvious.
In the scene Credence boards a boat, and it
seems like it might have been the one that
Newt was getting on at the end of the movie.
Producer David Heyman has said they didn't
want to make the set-up of Credence for the
next movie so obvious, but it feels like this
could have been a really good post-credits
stinger.
A scene cut early on in the movie featured
Jacob and his girlfriend, before he met Queenie.
The scene had Jacob returning from the bank
to the street where he lives to find his girlfriend
waiting for him.
Director David Yates explained that in the
deleted scene "she runs down the street [and
asks Jacob] 'How did it go?
Did you get your loan?'"
When Jacob replies that the bank didn't give
it to him, she takes off her engagement ring
and leaves him.
J.K.
Rowling originally wanted the scene cut from
the final script, but Yates insisted on filming
it as he thought it would be a touching moment.
Yates said that it was cut in the end because
it was no longer needed to help the audience
empathise with Jacob by that point.
There's a really wonderful cut scene which
was teased in one of the trailers.
The snippet we did see in the trailer is with
Jacob and Newt who are sat down in his menagerie,
smiling and applauding with Jacob saying "I
wanna be a wizard."
This was part of a much longer scene in which
Queenie and Tina sing the Ilvermorny school
song as part of the discussion that Newt,
Tina and Queenie are having about whether
Hogwarts or Ilvermony is the better wizarding
school.
Alison Sudol who plays Queenie is a singer
as well as an actress and she wrote the song
which both she and Katherine Waterston sang.
Unfortunately, it slowed down the momentum
of the film and was cut, but David Yates has
promised it will appear on the Blu-ray and
DVD extras.
Originally, there was an extended version
of the scene at Macy's department store.
While Jacob and Queenie were trying to catch
the Demiguise, which is charging around the
store, it tramples over Jacob, who grabs on
to the creature.
We then see Jacob getting dragged around by
something that's invisible.
Dan Fogler, who plays Jacob, has said the
moment is reminiscent of how Indiana Jones
gets pulled around behind a truck in Raiders
Of The Lost Ark.
The deleted scene finishes with a slapstick
moment as the Demiguise suddenly goes around
a corner sending Jacob crashing into a clothing
display, and as Queenie runs over to check
if he's OK, Jacob pulls on a hat and smiles
as if nothing had happened.
Eddie Redmayne who plays Newt Scamander has
revealed that there was a shirtless scene
that he had to spend seven months working
out for, but it ended up being deleted from
the final film!
J.K.
Rowling had written in the script that Newt
needed to be buff in the scene which showed
him into his briefcase and down into his menagerie
where he pulled off his shirt, revealing numerous
war wounds and scars.
So those were some of the scenes cut from
the theatrical release of Fantastic Beasts,
but what do we know about what we can look
forward to in the Fantastic Beasts sequel!?
Well, there are going to be four more movies
in the Fantastic Beasts franchise, each one
set in a different city.
The five movies take place over a period of
19 years, with the first film starting in
1926 and the saga ending in 1945.
Now, 1945 marks the year that Dumbledore and
Grindelwald had their epic battle that ends
the Global Wizarding War.
We already got the reveal of Grindelwald at
the end of this movie with a short cameo by
Johnny Depp, and a young Dumbledore has been
confirmed to appear in the sequel, although
at this point casting hasn't been confirmed.
Dumbledore was born in 1881 so the actor playing
him could well be in his late 40s.
Who would you like to see playing a young
Dumbledore in the sequels?
Another storyline was teased for the sequel
thanks to the mention of Leta Lestrange mid-way
through the film and again at the end when
Tina asked Newt more about Lestrange and he
seemed to be evasive in his answers.
Divergent series star Zoe Kravitz has already
been cast as Leta Lestrange and is confirmed
to appear in Fantastic Beasts 2.
It'll be interesting to see how her character
ties in with the Lestrange family from Harry
Potter and also with the reveal in The Cursed
Child that Bellatrix Lestrange is the mother
of Voldemort's child.
There was also an interesting tease that Jacob
may not have been completely obliviated at
the end of the movie after Queenie kissed
him and shielded him with her magic umbrella
after he stepped out into the rain.
After all, he seemed to recognise her when
he saw her in his bakery where he'd made lots
of cakes in the shape of the fantastic beasts.
Dan Fogler, the actor who plays Jacob, has
hinted that his character has likely been
affected by all the magic he's been in contact
with such as being bitten by a murtlap, eating
magical strudel, and being treated with Newt's
potions.
And although Newt, Tina, Queenie and Jacob
are all confirmed to appear in the next movie,
producer David Heyman believes that they may
not be at "the heart of all" the movies.
In fact, it seems that in the next film it
will actually be Credence and Grindelwald
who "will be the main players".
All of this means it looks like in the sequel
we're going to be getting more emphasis on
building the struggle between Dumbledore and
Grindelwald.
It's more like the Harry vs Voldemort conflict
from the Harry Potter franchise.
So, although the beasts will be taking something
of a back seat in the sequel, director David
Yates has confirmed they are planning on introducing
some new beasts, including a particularly
special Chinese fantastic beast.
So, guys, what do you think about the deleted
scenes and do you think any of them should
have stayed in the movie?
And what would you like to see happen in the
sequel?
Do let me know in the comments below.
If you enjoy finding out about deleted scenes
from movies you love, then check out my full
playlist below or you can also watch the full
Fantastic Beasts press conference with J.K.
Rowling and the cast below.
As always, if you enjoyed this, do please
like, share and subscribe for more videos
like this one.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time!
Yippee ki-yay movie lovers!